ما تعرض له الفلسطينيون في هذا الاجتماع
هو خداع كبير
ويؤسفني ايضا ان اقول ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه عادت لنفس النهج الذي فشل على
مدار 32 عاما
[موسيقى]
فيما يتعلق بالاستيطان هذا خدعه كبيره
لانه البيان يقول ان اسرائيل تلتزم بعدم
مناقشه وحدات جديده لاربع اشهر وعدم
المناقشه بؤر جديده لسته اشهر ولكنها لا
تحتاج لذلك لانه اسرائيل اقرت عشر الاف
وحده استيطانيه
واقرت 13 بؤره استيانيه جديده وسيستمروا
بالعمل بها واصلا مجلس التخطيط الذي يقر
هذه المستوطنات لن ينعقد اصلا قبل هذه
القمه الا بعد ثلاثه شهور اذا هاي عمليه
خداع كبيره وهذا يطرح السؤال هل ان هل ان
الاستيق قبول وبعده غير مقبول او انه بعد
ست شهور سيصبح مقبولا انا برايي هذا
التخلي عن مبدا اساسي وكبير وهو ان
الاستيطان برمته غير شرعي وغير قانوني
[موسيقى]
عمليا واضح ان هذا الاجتماع قرر عوده
التنسيق الامني ايضا المرفوض شعبيا ونعمه
نخشاه انه محاوله للضغط على الجانب
الفلسطيني لجره الى صراع داخلي ما تم
الاتفاق عليه هو فعلا تشكيل لجنه امنيه
مصريه اردنيه
اسرائيليه امريكيه وبوجود السلطه
الفلسطينيه لاعاده انتشار السلطه
الفلسطينيه في مناطق الف واعاده الاتفاق
كما كان قبل انتفاضه عام 2000 وللبدء في
مفاوضات مباشره بخصوص حلول نهائيه
[موسيقى]
ان اسرائيل تتصرف بالطرق جديده وسالب
جديده على مجد نظره الامريكيه هي طرق او
اساليب غير بنائه الضمانات الموجوده هو
الوجود العربي مصر
والاردني الاشقاء الاردنيين وايضا الوسيط
الامريكي الذي تعهد بان هذه
التفاهمات سوف يكون لها طريق للتنفيذ باي
وسيله تحديدا فتح او الممثليه الفلسطينيه
في الولايات المتحده وايضا فتح مكتب او
سفاره او قنصليه الولايات المتحده في
القدس الشرقيه المساله الاساسيه ان هذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لن تردع الا
بمقاومتها على الارض وبفرض العقوبات
والمقاطعه عليها وليس العوده الى التنسيق
الامني معها
[موسيقى]
السلطه الفلسطينيه ارتكبت خطائين الخطا
الاول سحب القرار من مجلس الامن والخطا
الثاني الذهاب الى هذا الاجتماع واخطر ما
في الامر تحويل الموضوع السياسي اساسا وهو
موضوع الاحتلال ونظام الابرتايد العنصري
وعدم شرعيه الاستيطان برمته تحويله الى
مجرد مساله امنيه كان الموضوع مجرد تهدئه
امنيه لا المساله الاكبر ان هناك اكثر
حكومه عنصريه واجراميه في تاريخ المنطقه
انا برايي المخرجات كلها تدل على ان
الجانب الفلسطيني كان ضعيفا في هذا اللقاء
وضعف السلطه لن يعالج بالعوده للتنسيق
الامني بل يعالج بالتوجه للوحده الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه وبتوحيد الصف الوطني الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]